the long-awaited whistleblower report is
Declassified and released but does it
help Democrats in their impeachment
efforts plus Trump fires back i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
these are days of breaking news and the
news is breaking a plenty this morning
the whistleblower report that was so
scrutinized and examined and talked
about in the in the past few days
finally it has been released to the
public a Declassified version which
means very mild word actions in the
whistleblower report now remember this
whistleblower report was basically the
inception of the entire Ukraine scandal
so the whistleblower report was filed
with the Inspector General of the
intelligence community by a member of
the intelligence community back on
September 9th the Congress was notified
about it on September 9th on September
11 president Trump restored aid to
Ukraine and the whistleblower report was
seen as sort of the be-all end-all in
terms of the beginning of the
examination of president Trump's
activities with regard to Ukraine so as
always I want to recap in 30 seconds
what exactly we are talking about
because this stuff gets very complex in
Joe Biden vice presidents of the United
States was presiding over the
withholding of 1 billion dollars in loan
guarantees to Ukraine he was doing so
explicitly saying he wanted a certain
prosecutor and in Viktor Shokan fired in
Ukraine because he was widely perceived
to be corrupt now at the same time
Shogun was allegedly investigating a
company on which on whose board Joe
Biden's son hunter Biden was sitting
there have been reports since that
perhaps that investigation had already
been basically put down and and was no
longer active nonetheless this raised a
lot of hackles and suspicions especially
in Trump world and with president from
specifically so President Trump then
employed Rudy Giuliani in the aftermath
of the election to Ukraine to
investigate what exactly went on with
hunter Biden and Joe Biden in Ukraine
among other issues including his
suspicions that the hack of the DNC may
not have been Russian after all that
crowds strike the company that was hired
to examine Hillary Clinton's servers was
in fact a Ukrainian proxy company and
all this had bit of a conspiracy theory
okay so that was the lead up to July in
July
president Trump withdrew aid from
Ukraine he did not really explain why he
was withdrawing aid from Ukraine
everybody sort of puzzled a week later
he held a call with the president of
Ukraine the transcript of that call was
the subject of yesterday's show
and the subject of tremendous
speculation in hubbub was president
Trump pressuring Ukraine to investigate
Joe Biden by withholding military aid
from them at a time when they are
effectively at war with Russian proxy
groups in Ukraine was he withholding the
sort of aid necessary to protect the
people of Ukraine in order to advance
his own domestic political agenda that
was the accusation the transcript came
out yesterday and the transcript
basically showed that while President
Trump was having conversations with
Ukraine about aid he was also having
conversations about ways that he thought
that Ukraine could clean up its corrupt
act what kind of cases were being
investigated there was no clear quid pro
quo but if you were inclined to believe
that Trump was pushing a quid pro quo
then the transcript certainly does not
disabuse you of that notion on the other
hand if you think that the transcript
definitely proves that Trump was in fact
pressuring Ukraine specifically to
investigate Joe Biden using American
taxpayer dollars as the lever well that
is not exactly proved by the transcript
either well the member of the
intelligence community got wind
secondhand of this phone call of this
this phone call and then he reported it
up the ladder to the Inspector General
of the intelligence community who
proceeded to report the existence of
this whistleblower report to Congress
well this led the Congress say okay
handover the whistleblower report so the
Trump administration originally said
okay well here's the transcript we'll
just give you the transcript but we
won't give you the whistleblower report
which led people to think okay well
what's in the whistleblower report they
don't want you to see well now the Trump
administration has turned over the
whistleblower report and has
Declassified the whistleblower report so
now we know what's in there and as it
turns out the Democrats who are sort of
counting on as late as yesterday we're
counting on the whistleblower report
going way above and beyond what the
transcript said if they believed the
transcript was not enough for
impeachment
maybe the whistleblower report would
point them in the right direction or
would be the other shoe to drop well it
turns out none of that is true it turns
out that the whistleblower report is
effectively a lot of hearsay
if the whistleblower report is
secondhand reported by somebody in the
intelligence community it mentions a few
different issues and none of which are
nearly as as sort of suspicious as even
the transcript of the original telephone
call
in fact the whistleblower report seems
to be milder in many ways and and less
harmful to the Trump administration of
President Trump personally then the
actual transcript of the phone call that
the Trump administration released
yesterday so now we have a copy of the
whistleblower complaint as much
ballyhooed whistleblower complaints and
the Republicans had been urging is
public release Democrats actually seem
to be a little bit less interested in
public release and now we see why
because the whistleblower report it
turns out kind of a nothing burger kind
of only because we already have the
transcripts we know what Trump said so
this looks like a summary of a document
that we already have where we now have
more information at our disposal because
the transcript has been made available
and the whistleblowers do when he wrote
the report
so the whistleblower report reads very
speculatively whereas the transcript is
the transcript and we went through it
word-for-word yesterday on the on
podcast in the radio show you can go
back and listen to those if you want
like a word-for-word analysis of what
exactly went down my read on that
transcript of the phone call is that
zalenski the president of Ukraine
clearly was attempting to broker some
sort of deal to restore military aid and
president Trump was talking in a
completely different direction which
again is not unique to conversations
with President Trump he does this a lot
you're talking to him about X and he is
talking to you about Y and he does not
listened and so there's no factual
meeting of the minds in the middle of
the conversation and that appears to be
the case in that conversation like many
of the conversations in which Trump
engages well now we have the
whistleblower complaint and we're gonna
go through it for you because
information first here on the show and
then we'll get to opinion we'll get to
that in just one moment first all of
this stuff may make you uncomfortable
all this impeachment talk but there's
one thing that should make you very
comfortable that is your underwear Tommy
John doesn't just claim to be the most
comfortable underwear on the planet they
actually have the stats to back it up
like how about this number seven million
that is the number of pairs of Tommy
John underwear they've sold with ninety
six percent of their customers rating
them with four stars or greater Tommy
John underwear they're the best
revolutionary the legs had never ride up
the waist bands never rolled down Tommy
John does more than just underwear
they've got 750 products online if super
soft lounge where they've got polo
shirts they've got apparel that all
sorts of good stuff for you to wear plus
dudes here's something for the ladies in
your life after two years and countless
hours of obsessing over every small
detail Tommy John is proud to introduce
the most comfortable bras on the planet
if you prefer to shop in stores you can
find them in over 1,200 retail locations
across the country including Nordstrom
stores nationwide Tommy John no
adjustment needed I know that my wife
has been using Tommy John products and
she
she raves about them she says they are
just fantastic you should prioritize
were uncomfortable underwear after all
you're in them all day long
hurry on over to Tommy John calm /ban
right now to get 20% off your first
order that is Tommy John calm /ban for
20% off Tommy John calm /ban go check
them out right now really the product is
just fantastic ok so now to the actual
text of the whistleblower complaint
because we want to prevent we're going
to provide you all the information
you're an adult you can make your own
decisions on what you think the
information means but I'm gonna provide
you the information I'll give you some
analysis along the way so here is the
whistleblower report dear chairman burr
and chairman chef I am reporting an
urgent concern in accordance with the
procedures outlined in 50 US Code 3033
this letter is unclassified when
separated from the attachment in the
course of my official duties I have
received information from multiple US
government officials that the President
of the United States is using the power
of his office to solicit interference
from a foreign country in the twenty20
u.s. election this interference includes
among other things pressuring a foreign
country to investigate one of the
president's main domestic political
rivals the president's personal lawyer
mr. Rudy Giuliani is a central figure in
this effort an attorney general bar
appears to be involved as well now again
because this is based on second-hand
information and now appears that
Attorney General Barr was not really
involved in this in this particular
investigation the reason presumably that
the whistleblower is saying this is
because he had a secondhand report that
Trump mentioned attorney general Barr
and Rudy Giuliani in his conversation
with zalenski but as we now know Barr
really had nothing to do with anything
that's just Trump mouthing off because
the way Trump thinks the way his brain
works as he goes Giuliani's man you know
who else's matter William Baier you
should talk to both of them well one of
them is the Attorney General one of them
is Trump's personal attorney their
missions do not match ok so remember the
whistleblower knows less is very
important the whistleblower knew less
when writing this complaint then you and
I now know about what happened in that
conversation with szalinski because you
and I have gone through the transcript
of the conversation the whistleblower
had no access to that transcript and so
is operating off secondhand sources so
what's more important the primary or the
secondary sources
obviously he answers the primary sources
ok so there there are a few wrinkles
here that will add some fire to the
democratic investigation
a little bit at least give them some
areas where they can push in the
investigation so the whistleblower
complaint says over the past four months
more than a half a dozen US officials
have informed me of various facts
related to this effort the information
provided here in was relayed to me in
the course of official interagency
business it is routine for US officials
with responsibility for a particular
regional our functional portfolio to
share such information with one another
in order to inform policy making and
analysis in other words this guy's
saying I'm not a political hack out
there to get Trump people are just sort
of coming to me with all the information
that's important because Trump has
suggested that this whistleblower is in
fact a political hack who favors Joe
Biden and the Inspector General himself
said that there may be political bias at
work here and by the way important to
note here the whistleblower himself
wants to be able to testify in front of
Congress but his lawyers according to
the New York Times are saying that he
hopes to remain anonymous good luck with
that good luck with that you've just put
forth one of the most one of the most
bombshell political documents in modern
political history that could lead to the
impeachment of the President of the
United States for the third time in
American history and you want to remain
anonymous and your good luck good luck
dude
he says I was not I mean this is on page
one the whistleblower I was not a direct
witness to most of the events described
however I found my colleagues accounts
of these events to be credible because
in almost all cases multiple officials
recounted fact patterns that were
consistent with one another in addition
a variety of information consistent with
these private accounts has been reported
publicly it's again
he knows less than you do when you
writes this report
he doesn't know as much about the
transcript you know more you've heard it
you've read it
he says I'm deeply concerned that the
actions described below constitute a
serious or flagrant problem abuse or
violation of law or executive order that
does not include differences of opinions
concerning public policy matters
consistent with the definition of an
urgent concern under the law I am
therefore fulfilling my duty to report
this information through proper legal
channels to the relevant authorities now
this is the right thing to do I mean it
is if you're suspicious that something
is going on reporting it up the chain is
the right thing to do we can get to the
media would be the wrong thing to do
there is something to the notion that
there are members of the intelligence
community who despise Trump and have
been consistently leaking material that
would supposedly damage him for the past
three years going all the way back to
the campaign but moving forward through
the investigate
of Trump Russia ties and there is a
belief that the intelligence community
basically that maybe this whistleblower
far from being SuperDuper honest as we
have been told by people including
Joseph Maguire who is the president's
own appointee as Acting Director of
National Intelligence may be the
whistleblower really doesn't like Trump
and the whistleblower is seeking to as
as they say who the president and do
that because he has access to
information however that works he didn't
do the wrong thing by leaking it to the
press right you gotta give him credit
for that
right he did report it up the chain he
used common sense protocols he did
everything by the book and for all the
people who are out there like well this
is just like Edward Snowden said it
would be if you reported up the chain
nothing happens
actually if you report it up the chain
as opposed to you know running to Russia
like Edward Snowden did you know what
happens this like an impeachment inquiry
anyway he says I'm also concerned that
these actions pose risks to US national
security and undermine the US
government's efforts to deter and
counter foreign interference in US
elections to the best of my knowledge
the entirety of the statement is
unclassified okay
now he gets to the meat of the matter so
he says the July 25th presidential phone
call now here's the thing
again we've read the transcript so we
can analyze how true to form this
whistleblowers complaints are against
the content of the transcript itself
cases early in the morning of 25th of
July the president spoke by telephone
with ukrainian President Vladimir
Solinsky I do not know which side
initiated the call this was the first
publicly acknowledged call between the
two leaders since a brief congratulatory
call after zalenski won the presidency
on April 21st
multiple White House officials with
direct knowledge of the call informed me
that after an initial exchange of
pleasantries the president used the
remainder of the call to advance his
personal interests namely he sought to
pressure the Ukrainian leader to take
actions to help the president's 2020
re-election bid you know that's
interpretation it is and the Biden part
probably is designed to advance his his
personal interests you could say it is
also possible the president was just
listing off stuff he thought was corrupt
in Ukraine which is also how the
president's mind works you don't know he
can be suspicious but again you're gonna
1ph you need more than just you're
suspicious according to the White House
officials who had direct knowledge of
the call the president pressured mr.
szalinski to inter alia initiate or
continue an investigation into the
activities of former vice president
Joseph Biden in his son
assistant purportedly uncovering
allegations of Russian interference in
the 2016 US presidential election
actually originated in Ukraine with a
specific request the Ukrainian leader
located and turn over servers used by
the DNC and examined by the US Cyber
Security from CrowdStrike which
initially reported that Russian hackers
had penetrated the DNC's networks in
2016 and meet or speak with two people
the president names explicitly as his
personal envoys on these matters
Giuliani and Barr to whom the president
referred multiple times in tandem okay
so a couple of things one it is
important to distinguish between these
various requests so to start the
whistleblowers complaint at least
factually I'm not saying his
interpretation but factually this is
accurate right we've read the transcript
this is a fair representation of the
phone call although it is adding a
patina of opinion which is that Trump
pressured zalenski as opposed to Trump
requested that Solinsky do X and didn't
overtly connect it to military aid also
the question is whether Trump is
requesting this stuff because it helps
Trump or because it is in the interests
of the United States to find out what
exactly happened with things like
CrowdStrike at least in Trump's mind
okay the president also praised
Ukraine's prosecutor general mr. yuriy
lutsenko
and suggested that Solinsky might want
to keep him in his position note
starting in March 2019 mr. Lutz Anka
made a series of public allegations many
of which he later walked back about the
Biden family's activities in Ukraine
Ukrainian officials purported
involvement in the 2016 US election and
the activities of the US Embassy in Kiev
the White House officials who told me
this information say the whistleblower
it says the whistleblower we're deeply
disturbed by what had transpired in the
phone call they told me there was
already a discussion ongoing with White
House lawyers about how to treat the
call because of the likelihood and the
officials retelling that they had
witnessed the president abuse his office
for personal gain now this is weird okay
this is the part of the complaint that I
frankly do not understand so much people
are treating it as a bombshell that
Trump quote-unquote hid the conversation
and the president has the power of
classification and declassification
normally transcripts with foreign
leaders are not revealed to anyone
because that does violate the
president's unitary power of the
executive plenary power over foreign
policy my Trump actually violated
presidential principle in releasing the
transcripts who had been fully within
his rights really to say I'm not
releasing
transcript because hey I'm the president
of the United States none of your
beeswax
so the the complaint seems to be that
the White House officials sort of hid it
within particular executive channels
where they wouldn't normally hide it
maybe out of fear that it would be
leaked by unflattering members of the
intelligence community were such fears
truly unbathed considering that the
intelligence community then took
secondhand accounts of those
conversations and spun it into a
whistleblower report it doesn't seem to
me like those suspicions are wildly off
the mark now does that mean that Trump
didn't engage in an underlying activity
that's bad no doesn't mean that we still
need more answers about the underlying
activity and whether Trump was in fact
utilizing taxpayer dollars to benefit
himself yeah we do need more information
about that but the specific complaint
which is that Trump took this
conversation and then sort of hid it in
a safe somewhere he's the president
that's within his power I'm kind of
confused as to why that would be in and
of itself violation and that that is
that is an area like he could have he
could have ordered the transcript of the
conversation fully destroyed and that
would've been within his power they're
classified I didn't have to declassify
them he did he turned them over in just
a second we'll get to the rest of the
whistleblow report and then we'll get to
the big hearing that is happening today
with joseph mcguire who's the acting
head of the national intelligence
services first let's talk about safety
so as you may imagine I am deeply
concerned about safety I'm paranoid
about it that's because I get death
threats stalkers and all sorts of
weirdos and the fact is that because I
am concerned about safety
I am constantly trying to ensure safety
on my property and that's why I use ring
products I mean I literally just put a
bunch of ring products around my house
rings mission is to make it neighborhood
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protects millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you'll get an alert you'll be able to
see hear and speak to them all from your
phone this definitely makes me feel
safer it makes my wife feel safer I know
who's on my property at all times as a
subscriber you have a special offer on a
ring welcome kit available right now at
ring.com
slash pen the kit includes the ring
video doorbell - and a chime Pro and
that's just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home
today go to ring.com slash man that is
ring.com slash been additional terms may
apply again i love ring products i have
them outside my house i have them all
around my house like that they are
making sure that my house is safe and
that matters so much to me i have kids
and go check out ring.com slash men make
sure that you have built a ring of
security around your home ring comm
slash been and get a special deal when
you use that slash better okay so the
whistleblower complaint continues they
say the ukrainian side was the first to
publicly acknowledge the phone call on
the evening of july 25th a readout was
posted on the website of the ukrainian
president that contained the following
line it's translated donald trump
expressed his conviction that the new
Ukrainian government will be able to
quickly improve Ukraine's image and
complete the investigation of corruption
cases that have held back cooperation
between Ukraine in the United States now
I'm not sure why that super suspicious
the Obama administration pressured
Ukraine to investigate Paul Manafort
that was legitimate how manna fort was a
suspicious character so that in and of
itself should not raise the hackles of
the whistleblower in the absence of this
other information now what the
whistleblower report does do is set the
predicate for further investigation
meaning he's saying they're a bunch of
people who know about this stuff and you
should go ask them questions the
whistleblower says based on my
understanding there were approximately a
dozen White House officials who listened
to the call a mixture of policy
officials and duty officers in the White
House Situation Room as is customary the
officials I spoke with told me that
participation in the call had not been
restricted in advance because everyone
expected it would be a routine call with
a foreign leader which again goes to
president Trump's tweet saying it was a
routine call with a foreign leader you
think I'd be stupid enough to offer a
quid pro quo in front of 20 witnesses
and then he named some names he says
that a State Department official a guy
named duty Ulrich Brett ball listened in
on the call he said I was not the only
non White House official to receive a
readout of the call multiple State
Department and Intel community officials
were also briefed on the contents of the
call okay that is section 1 of the
whistleblower report then he says there
were efforts to restrict access to
records related to the call he said I
learned from multiple US officials that
senior White House officials had
intervened to quote unquote locked down
all records of the phone call especially
the official word-for-word transcript
now this is sort of a moot point cuz
again the White House just spilled it
out there I Trump sure said ok boom
enjoy so it's kind of like it's hard to
call
a cover-up when it's now available to
you and me and to everybody hey then
there is section 3 ongoing concerns so
the idea here is that members of the
Ukrainian government basically believed
that they had to pursue investigations
beneficial to Trump in order to get aid
now their perception is not necessarily
the reality that Trump pressured meaning
that we may have a he-said he-said
situation here in which the Ukrainian
government believed that Trump wants in
a quid pro quo and Trump didn't actually
want to quid pro quo right that is quite
plausible and when you read that
zalenski conversation you kind of get
that impression
solinsky's they're going what can I do
for you mr. president whether I have to
do to get military aid and from slike
you know there's like a bunch of things
that I think you should do just
generally and then zelinsky's like so I
get military aid in terms like you know
this awesome
Giuliani like that's how the transcript
reads but this whistleblower says I
learned from multiple US officials that
on or about August 2nd Giuliani
reportedly traveled to Madrid to meet
with one of President solinsky's
advisors the US officials characterized
this meeting not reported publicly at
the time as a direct follow-up to the
president's call with mr. szalinski
about the cases they had discussed again
it is not a violation of law for
Giuliani to meet with members of the
Ukrainian government to gather
information relevant yes to the 2020
campaign it is a violation of law if the
president is withholding military aid
based on the unwillingness of Ukraine to
do so the whistleblower complaint says
on July 26 the day after the call the
especial representative for Ukraine
negotiations kurt volker visited Kiev
and met with zalenski and a variety of
Ukrainian political figures ambassador
Volcker was accompanied in his meetings
by US ambassador to the European Union
Gordon Sunland based on multiple
readouts of these meetings were counted
to me by various US officials
ambassadors Volcker and sunland
reportedly provided advice to the
Ukrainian leadership about how to
navigate the demands the President had
made of zalenski again this does not go
to quid-pro-quo
maybe he made the demands and the
demands were broader than merely the
things he brought up and the Obama
administration made a bunch of
anti-corruption demands Joe Biden made
specific anti-corruption demands of the
Ukrainian fire this prosecutor you don't
get aid the question is whether this was
done to benefit Trump politically and
whether it was done to target his
domestic political opponents
and then the rest of the whistleblower
complaint is basically just a bunch of
reports on public recorded stuff I mean
it's a bunch of references to articles
from Bloomberg and Fox News and the hill
talking about how various characters did
various things I mean it literally he's
just recounting stories from the New
York Times and he's saying these stories
make me suspicious okay so he floats
this thing up the chain and after
floating this thing up there's there's
about one paragraph here maybe two
paragraphs that are redacted in the
appendix and the and you know the the
there's really not too much else here
I'm kind of stunned that there's not
much more than this and you can see the
media playing it up like that the big
story here is that Trump urged that the
transcript be locked down but the
transcript is now available to everybody
so again this is sort of like when there
were big stories about how Trump was
gonna fire Muller and then he never
fired Muller how Trump was engaged in a
cover-up and then there was not really a
cover-up there are a few other details
in the complaint races I learned from US
officials that on or around May 14th the
president instructed vice-president pens
to cancels planned trip to Ukraine to
attend solinsky's inauguration Rick
Perry led the delegation instead
according to officials who was made
clear to them the president did not want
to meet with someone ski until he saw
hustling ski chose to act in office okay
again this is all vague this is all
incredibly incredibly vague and then
there is the Inspector General letter
which conveys this to Congress and says
I find this at least urgent and you
should take a look at it and that is
where things stood and then the Office
of the Director of National Intelligence
they said well this doesn't really raise
to the level of urgency it has nothing
to do at the intelligence community so
we don't have to convey this over and
that's what started off this whole
firestorm now in a second I want to get
to the Ukrainian perception versus the
trumpian perception and the big hearing
that's happening today with Joseph
McGuire the Acting Director of National
Intelligence we'll get to that in just
one second first but I'm a parent I have
two kids under six and I can tell you
the thing that I care about most in life
is making sure that my kids are set up
for success that means that I want them
to have the best resources available I
want them to get the best education and
one of the things that I had when I was
growing up but it was insufficient was
every so often you run into schoolwork
trouble and you need the tutor
and usually the way that you go get a
tutor is you like asking around to
somebody no math do you know somebody
who knows math now you're in high school
chemistry you know like to somebody no
high school chemistry and you find
somebody from your local community or
church or synagogue or just somewhere or
somebody online is a college student and
then you bring them in and maybe they
know chem it maybe they don't you know
tutor and finding a good tutor is
actually really really hard and if you
want to set your children up for success
having access to great tutors pretty
much on demand it's really really
helpful well this is where varsity
tutors comes in whether it's in person
or online
varsity tutors connect students with
expert instructors in anything from
early reader phonics to SAT test prep to
college courses unlike other programs
varsity tutors has a rigorous tutor
vetting process and it ensures your
child is working with the best tutors
from the top schools in the country
which is just awesome
the online live learning platform is a
two way video chat and collaborative
work board to make learning easy and
convenience he actually can do this
online so no matter where you live you
have access to a tutor varsity tutors
has a four point nine out of five
satisfaction rating you can empower your
child today I've already started working
with varsity tutors looking for a tutor
for my daughter when it comes to math
because yes she's young but who can't
use a leg up to receive up to 250 bucks
and a free consultation with an
education director go to varsity tutors
comm slash Ben that's varsity tutors
comm slash Ben for 250 bucks off give
your child the confidence and keys to
success today at varsity tutors dot-com
/ Ben go check them out it really is
doing your kid a service yeah whether
they're falling behind or you just want
them to be ahead varsity tutors comm /
Ben fantastic fantastic company
okay so there was a story that came out
today talking about how an advisor to
Ukraine suggested that Biden was key to
all of this his name is Sir hey leshenka
and he told the ABC news that after
zelinsky's election they wanted to speak
with Trump but as ABC News after weeks
of discussion with American officials
Ukrainian officials came to recognize a
precondition to any executive
correspondents the advisor said it was
clear that President Trump will only
have communications if they will discuss
the Biden case said sir Haley Shenko an
anti-corruption advocate and former
member of Ukraine's Parliament who know
who now acts as an advisor to zalenski
this issue was raised many times I know
that Ukrainian officials understood
mashenka also talked about Rudy
Giuliani's push for a Biden
investigation and said he believes then
prosecutor general Murray let's hurry
let's say
invented the investigations that
Giuliani pushed as part of an effort to
keep his job okay so was Ukraine trying
to make guarantees to Trump to get aid
or was Trump trying to push Ukraine or
is it possible that Ukraine was taking
away from all the conversations that
Trump wanted a quid pro quo but Trump
never actually asked for a quid pro quo
if there's one dot that has to be
connected here and nobody is connected
if the whistleblower report doesn't do
it there's a lot of speculation here so
basically where things currently stand
is that unless the Democrats can uncover
somebody who can say just without a
doubt that President Trump informed me
he's withholding aids Ukraine unless the
Ukrainians investigate his chief
political riedel rival Joe Biden not
just Trump is withholding aid from
Ukraine until they fix up their
corruption problems we're investigating
a myriad of topics or even investigate
the 2016 election which is relevant to
the United States broadly not just with
regard to Trump it has to be with regard
to Biden so there's a very specific
thing that has to be fulfilled in order
for a quid pro quo to have happened and
impeachment to really be justified
without that there's just not enough
there's just not enough now the
Washington Post got a report wrong
yesterday apparently and this is one of
the problems here is there was all this
smoke before any of this had been
revealed from mentioning Biden eight
times on a phone call according to the
transcript he mentioned in three times
talk about from openly engaging in a
promise with the Ukrainians no such
promise is made right all of that oh
that media overreach cuts in trumps
favor there's another one in these
stories yesterday The Washington Post
reported that the Acting Director of
National Intelligence threatened to
resign over concerns that the White
House might attempt to force him to
stonewall Congress in his testimony the
official said that Joseph Maguire warned
the White House he was not willing to
withhold information from Congress where
he is scheduled to testify in open and
closed hearings on Thursday but Maguire
denies this he issued a statement he
said at no time have I considered
resigning my position since assuming
this role on August 16 2019 I've never
quit anything in my life I'm not gonna
start now I'm committed to leading the
intelligence community to address the
diverse and complex threats facing our
nation the White House also said this is
actually not true the Washington Post
says they stand by their story okay so
with that controversy brewing and with
the credibility of the media
always in a significant amount of
question joseph mcguire appears before
the House Intelligence Committee on
Thursday and and McGuire I think rightly
says that he did not deem the complaint
as urgent under the definition of legal
statute but when President Trump says
this was just a partisan hack job he
says no you know I have no evidence in
that the whistleblower acted in good
faith I want to stress that I believe
that the whistleblower and the Inspector
General have acted in good faith
throughout I have every reason to
believe that they have done everything
by the book and followed the law
respecting the privileged nature of the
information and patiently waiting while
the executive privilege issues were
resolved okay so that is I mean he's
basically saying we follow procedures
right and the procedures were followed
and that's fine
now we see the interpretations so in a
second we'll get to the Democratic
interpretation and then we'll get to the
Republican interpretation of all of
these events and where exactly we are
where exactly things stand because
president Trump is is really going to
war we'll get to all of that in just one
moment first let's talk about the
difficulty of creating healthy habits so
it is very difficult to change your
lifestyle it's very difficult to change
it you know diets it sounds like a quick
fix and then you end up on a diet for
like three weeks and you feel good and
then you get bored and you stop doing it
or you go to the gym and you're like aw
it's the new year I'm going to the gym
I'm gonna stay in shape this year and
three weeks later is sitting on your
couch eating potato chips while watching
TV
well in fact is you do need to change
your habits wouldn't it be great if
there were an app that helped you change
those habits good news there is it's
called noon and it really is fantastic
I've been using it myself to get in
better listen I was already in good
shape it's getting magnificent God like
a hollow ask shape right specific goals
are achievable with noon right you can
you can tell them how much weight you
want to lose and they set up a program
that helps you achieve it they are
constantly giving you all sorts of
information about how you can change
your habits and things to watch out for
and you're in a bad mood today and how
to get over the hump they give you a
social network that you can connect in
with people who are trying to do the
same things that you are all of this is
supremely supremely important new hinges
habits it's not just about a diet it
changes habits is it an easy and it's a
healthy and easy to stick to way
life I've been using it consistently
I've recommended it to my parents as
well you don't have to change everything
in one day small steps make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noon
that's n om dot-com / Shapiro what do
you have to lose visit noon calm /
Shapiro and start your trial today
that's Noom calm / apparel is the last
weight loss program you will ever need
ok so president Trump is is fighting
back today so president Trump went on
Twitter and in all capital letters which
means that he is is very serious he
tweeted out the Democrats are trying to
destroy the Republican Party and all
that it stands for stick together play
their game and fight hard Republicans
our country is at stake okay and then he
the press secretary gave a statement
today about the Declassified
whistleblower report saying nothing has
changed with the release of this
complaint which is nothing more than a
collection of third-hand accounts of
events and cobbled together press
clippings all of which show nothing
improper the president took the
extraordinary and transparent step of
releasing the full unredacted
Declassified transcript of his call with
president Solinsky which forms the heart
of the complaint as well as the
complaints itself that's because he has
nothing to hide the White House will
continue to push back on the hysteria
and and that is fair right remember I've
been saying for this entire week that
basically there are three cases that
could be put forth for impeachment and
two of them are insufficient one is that
the the case could be that Trump is
covering things up there's no evidence
of a cover-up none he's now revealed
everything so where's the cover-up to
would be that the transcript itself
right the mere attempt to garner
information from the Ukrainians amounted
to some sort of campaign finance
violation that is very very weak sauce
Hillary Clinton worked with the
Ukrainians back in 2016 to gather
information on Trump the Obama
administration pressured the Ukrainians
to prosecute Paul manna for basically
and then there's three which is the quid
pro quo and that has yet to be proved
okay in a second we're gonna get to how
we are now watching the same set of
facts and two completely different
worlds of interpretation we'll get to
that in just one second first you have
to go over to daily where calm and
subscribe $9.99 a month gets you the
rest of this show live it also gets you
an additional two hours of the show
every day and on busy news weeks like
this one you want the updates later in
the day because things are dropping like
it's hot I mean it's happening all like
stuff is happening the whole day and we
are here to update you basically we have
now become an all day show for your view
pleasure go check us out over at daily I
mean literally all day yesterday we did
the podcast we need two additional hours
of radio and we did a backstage all
about this topic okay so that's five
hours of content that I brought to you
all you have to do to get that content
is subscribe that also means you can ask
us questions become part of the mailbag
it means you get early access to our
Sunday special and we have a bevy of
fantastic Sunday specials that are
coming up in the next few weeks I can't
wait for you to see them really are
great go subscribe right now 99 bucks
gets you this the greatest in all
beverage vessels cast your eyes upon it
and despair that you have it not but you
could have it for 99 bucks a year ago
check us out we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay now to the two narratives that are
that are coming out of of the various
camps oh you got the Democratic
narrative and this is the one being
pushed by Adam Schiff who again has very
very little credibility this is a person
who was so far out over his skis he was
no longer connected with them during the
Trump Russia hearings and he was out
there every day on CNN he had set up a
pup tent outside the greenroom at CNN I
mean he was living on the streets of San
Francisco
I mean like he really was like living on
the street outside the CNN headquarters
so that he could be there at a moment's
notice he spent more time in the CNN
greenroom that he did in Congress and
pretty much everything he said turned
out not to be true well now he is
suggesting that everything he's now
saying is true right that this is clear
convincing evidence of so here's Adam
chef getting out over his skis again
suggesting that we now have graphic
evidence the president betrayed his oath
of office yesterday we were presented
with the most graphic evidence yet that
the president the United States has
betrayed his oath of office betrayed his
oath to defend our national security and
betrayed his oath to defend our
Constitution for yesterday we were
presented with a record of a call
between the President of the United
States and the president of Ukraine in
which the president our president
sacrificed our national security and our
Constitution for his personal political
benefit
okay so again that is the part that has
not actually yet improved races that he
sacrificed our national security in our
Constitution for his personal political
benefit is a conclusion driven from a
read of the transcript alone they
haven't connected that dot okay the
transcript does not have an explicit
quid pro quo now as I said yesterday
there is a plausible read of it in which
it's Trump pressuring Ukraine there's
also a plausible read of it in which
it's from not pressuring Ukraine but at
no point is Trump say anywhere in the
document by the way if you do X Y & Z
military aides back on the day like he
doesn't say that anywhere in the
conversation that's not a thing that
happens and this has led to the
Republican interpretation which is Devin
Nunez saying Devin Nunes the the
Republican from California and president
Trump's favorite Republican on the House
Intelligence Committee of he accused
Democrats of trying to obtain
every possible thing about Donald Trump
and he put this into the context of
Democrats digging deep on the steel
dossier and Trump Russia he basically
says listen you guys have have had you
know eight I'm trying to find a clean
way to say this you guys have had a very
strong desire to get president Trump
impeached since the very beginning and
now this is just the latest iteration of
a story we've already seen before
Ukrainian official sir hey leshenka
was a source for nelly or wife of
Department of Justice official Bruce or
as she worked on the anti-trump
operation conducted by fusion GPS and
funded by the Democrats and of course
Democrats on this very committee
negotiated with people who they thought
were Ukrainians in order to obtain nude
pictures of Trump okay I believe that
that is a reference to a prank phone
call that Adam Schiff was engaged and so
Nunes is basically saying listen you
guys been going after Trump since the
beginning and you got nothing and you
still got nothing so those are the two
competing the two competing strains over
all of this
now that the Democrats do have a bit of
a pickle on their hands and that is that
a majority of the house does now support
the impeachment inquiry that was gonna
be obvious as soon as Nancy Pelosi
endorsed this thing as soon as as soon
as Nancy Pelosi endorsed this thing it
was pretty obvious that impeachment was
going to happen if you had to put your
money down you say that impeachment
happens in the house and nothing happens
in the Senate why well Nancy Pelosi
cannot afford to announce an impeachment
inquiry and then say oh by the way we're
not impeaching him I mean that is going
to be a very rough move for her if she
if she puts impeachment on the table and
then says well we couldn't come up with
anything so I guess he's okay okay that
is not a thing that's going to happen
once she says the I board it's now
happening my Democrats are going to vote
to impeach Trump it's a foregone
conclusion the question is whether that
is justified and whether Republicans in
the Senate will join or whether anything
in the house will join except for Justin
a MASH who now considers himself an
independent the problem is that there's
not a lot of suggestion that the in the
polling data that Americans actually
want impeachment there's an article from
the New York Times saying for many
Democratic voters around the country the
prospect of an explosive
in battle in Washington left that left
them nervous Republicans were mostly
unmoved so there's not a lot of public
approval for impeachment at this point
there's not a lot of pull data on
impeachment but there's a there's a
story yesterday as a new poll said the
majority of Americans were against the
impeachment and removal of President
Trump those from Quinnipiac University
4% of Republicans and 73 percent of
Democrats support impeachment however
overall the majority of Americans do not
support impeachment the overall numbers
57 percent no 37 percent yes
now of course Democrats want Trump
impeached because they're Democrats but
overall this is not a winning issue for
Democrats especially if they don't have
a smoking gun so Democrats are really
running a bit of a risky game here right
now what they feel it's like okay fine
so people don't support impeachment so
we impeach what's the big deal he
doesn't get removed from office and then
Elizabeth Warren runs on the basis of
him being corrupt and wins so they're
banking on from having an underlying
popularity problem in a way that Bill
Clinton did not write Bill Clinton's a
pretty popular president until the
impeachment hearings began he was less
popular afterward but still pretty
popular and his popularity actually
increased as the impeachment hearings
went on and as Democrats successfully if
falsely argued that the whole thing was
about sex but Trump they feel is not
Clinton Trump does not have anything
like the underlying approval ratings
that Bill Clinton did and so what you're
starting to see is the Democrats make
excuses for why they're going to impeach
Trump even without a quid pro quo
they're shifting the standard pretty
dramatically here so top House Democrats
for example put out a statement saying
no quid pro quo is required to betray
our country it's a statement from Schiff
Jerrold Nadler Elijah Cummings in LA
dangle they called the the transcript
and unambiguous damning shocking abuse
of the office of the presidency for
personal political gain again it's hard
to say that Barack Obama in 2012 pledged
the Russians flexibility in the in in
relation to the upcoming election that
was bad was it impeachable probably not
because maybe Obama wanted flexibility
for the Russians from a sort of
defensive standpoint because he thought
to be good
for the country a personal political
benefit and the country's interests are
not necessarily completely completely
separate is the problem the statement
continued let us be quick clear no quid
pro quo is required to betray our
country Trump asked two foreign
governments to interfere in our
elections that is betrayal enough again
pretty solid info according John Solomon
of the hill that the Obama
administration was pressuring the
Ukrainians to investigate Paul Manafort
who ended up being Trump's campaign
manager plus Hillary Clinton was working
with the Ukrainians to gather dirt on
Trump and mana for nonetheless you're
seeing the Democrats shift their
standard because they know that they now
have to impeach they've gone too far not
to impeach and they don't have the goods
so instead they're shifting the standard
so you got Neal Katyal the acting
Solicitor General in the Obama
administration has a piece in The New
York Times today calls Trump doesn't
need to commit a crime to be kicked out
of office so this went from Trump
definitely committed a crime to what he
did is bad but now criminal - it doesn't
have to be criminal at all we can
impeach him for any reason whatsoever
I can't y'all says the potential
criminality of the president's conduct
is not the full picture
our founders deliberately drafted the
Constitution's impeachment clause to
ensure the potential grounds for
impeachment would cover more than
criminal activity he said that he says
this is brazen conduct it took place the
day after Robert Muller testified in
Congress perhaps when Trump felt
liberated from the shadow of the Russia
investigation he says to make matters
worse before the call record of that
conversation was released on Wednesday
Trump pointed to it as exculpatory
evidence which makes you wonder what
will be revealed about other calls or
contacts etcetera etcetera but the
bottom line is this Democrats are now
shifting the goalposts the goalposts
have now moved by a Oh C is is making
accusations that she can't back up Rea
AOC was on Chris Cuomo's show not
Fredo's show on CNN and she says without
evidence that Trump was was actively
withholding aid in order to achieve
personal political benefit that is the
dot that has not yet been connected we
are talking about here is the
president's essentially participating in
what looks like a series of events that
looks like extortion withholding aid to
an ally and then quote-unquote asking
for a favor - - to essentially benefit
yourself politically not
in the interest of the United States of
America but in the interests of your own
relatable okay so the Democrats are
shifting the standard now president
Trump is responding in a couple of ways
first of all he did a press conference
with the Ukrainian president Solinsky
Solinsky came out and said there's no
pressure that's pretty strong talking
point for Trump because if the ones he
says there was pressure then Trump at
the very least has a problem as onc says
there was no pressure now to be fair
zalinsky is trying to get military aid
from from stole so so if you are a
Democrat you're saying of course he says
that he's in the room with Trump what
else is he gonna say here's the Lensky
though saying there was no pressure I
think you read everything so I think you
read text we had I think good phone call
it was normal we spoke about many things
and I so I think and you are ready that
nobody pushed it pushed me yes okay and
there's Trump filling in the gap even
see Trump is super irritated by all of
this obviously he doesn't think that he
pressured the Ukrainians for this stuff
at the very least when Trump then came
out yesterday said I fully support
transparency which by the way again he
has now revealed two documents he did
not have to reveal the whistleblower
memo and the full transcript of the call
we were gonna do this anyway but I've
informed them all of the House members
that I fully support transparency on the
so-called whistleblower information even
though it was supposedly secondhand
information which is sort of interesting
and other things have come out about the
whistleblower that are also maybe even
more interesting but also insist on
transparency from Joe Biden and his son
hunter on the millions of dollars that
have been quickly and easily taken out
of Ukraine and China by the way Joe
Biden is hardest hit in all this Trump
will likely survived this entire attempt
Joe Biden will not his candidacy is
basically over he was asked yesterday
while leaving a car about Hunter Biden
there are new allegations by the by the
way that other members of Biden's family
routine
we try to take advantage of the fact
that they are related to Biden to get
special benefits there's a I think it's
his brother who was trying to join a
company having do with cancer research
who's promising members of the company
that Biden's cancer moonshot would go to
fund that research anyway here's Biden
walking away from a car well not
answering any questions about the hunter
Biden stuff mr. Biden mr. Biden can you
rinse it can you respond to criticism
that you and your son should not been
working in Ukraine at the same time they
just keep on walking
keep on walking meanwhile president from
says listen there was no quid pro quo
you know whatever you guys say there was
no quid pro quo he said this yesterday
from the UN I didn't do it you take a
look at that call it was perfect I
didn't do it there was no quid pro quo
but there was with Biden and there was
with these senators and they threatened
they said you do this you do that we're
not gonna give you votes that's that's
the real deal
yeah now what he's saying there is
actually true so it is true that back in
May there were several Democratic
senators including Bob Menendez of New
Jersey and I believe dick Durbin who
wrote a letter openly saying that if
Ukraine didn't investigate the the mana
for Trump connection and in connections
that Trump may have had with Ukraine and
Russia and if they didn't do that that
maybe they would withhold aid from
Ukraine so the Senate I mean Marc
Thiessen reported on this yesterday in
the Washington Post he said that this
what he's saying there is absolutely
100% true
now one of the problems here is that a
lot of the things that President Trump
talks about being worried about with
regard to corruption our stories that
have not really been substantiated right
that is where Democrats are honing in on
right there's a vulnerability here right
so Trump is saying I if I am withholding
aid from Ukraine it's over corrupted
stuff right he said this he said was
over corruption stuff but what Trump
perceives as corruption stuff may in
fact not really be corruption stuff it
may be stuff that Trump has sort of
heard about in the ether and now he's
channeling it into the general box of
corruption so for example he mentions
CrowdStrike in that in that call to
zalenski that is a reference to a
company called CrowdStrike
which is in intelligence data firm and
Hillary Clinton the DNC they turned over
their servers to CrowdStrike as opposed
to the FBI in the middle of an
investigation
those servers could be looked at and
audited to see who exactly had been
hacking in to to the servers and
CrowdStrike came up with the idea that
it was the Russians and Trump has always
been suspicious of that idea so he
mentions to the Ukrainians that maybe
CrowdStrike
is a Ukrainian owned company and that
may be the real DNC servers are still
out there in Ukraine and maybe it wasn't
the Russians after all who hacked the
whole thing now Trump may see that as
why won't you can't investigate that
it's corrupt in reality there's not a
lot of support for it this is why Trump
yesterday makes these sort of bizarre
statement that Hillary's deleted emails
might still be in Ukraine I don't know
the and like I don't know where he's
getting this from or why people think
that information is particularly
credible but that doesn't go to Trump's
personal political benefit alone if he
actually believes that the Ukrainian
that there was a Ukrainian proxy company
that was that was actually hacking the
DNC's emails as opposed to the Russians
that does have some pretty significant
national security ramifications for the
United States not just personal
ramifications for Trump yes yeah I think
they could very well for those in this
we're sure like that way because frankly
I think that one of the great crimes
committed is Hillary Clinton deleting
33,000 emails after Congress Center is
subpoena think of that okay so again I
don't know what he's referring to here
but that's that in and of itself the
fact that president from believes a lot
of things that he reads on Infowars that
does not necessarily mean that he's
acting out of concert with the interest
of the United States it means that he
perceives the interest of the United
States differently maybe based on
factual in correctness but not
necessarily for his political benefit
and says there is that and meanwhile
Mike Pence was making the case that
President Trump has never threatened aid
to Ukraine he also said president Trump
has stood strong with Ukraine that is a
point that is worth noting I mean the
Trump administration support for Ukraine
has been significantly stronger than the
Obama administration support was that
still doesn't answer the two outstanding
questions I have from yesterday and by
the way if Trump doesn't answer those
questions that doesn't mean he's
impeachable because the burden of proof
is on the prosecution but it would be
good to have answers to why did Trump
cut off the aid and also why was the
state that
Hartmann sending Rudy Giuliani's Ukraine
like that that's a weird thing Rudy
being in Ukraine I get Rudy being sent
by the State Department I don't get so
much but in any case here's my pen
saying that Trump stood strong with
Ukraine that is effectively true the
United States of America has stood
strong with Ukraine ever since the
Russian military overran Crimea and has
been underwriting a savage war in the
Donbass province of Ukraine different
from the last administration we've
actually been providing defensive
weapons the Obama administration was
sending them blankets and pillows but
this president said nope we're gonna
stand for the territorial integrity and
the sovereignty of Ukraine we've
provided them with weapons the ability
to defend themselves okay that part is
certainly true so here is where things
currently stand in synopsis we have the
transcript the transcript is a Rorschach
test if you think Trump was offering a
quid pro quo it looks like a quid pro
quo if you think he wasn't it doesn't it
really is just a referendum on your own
mind less a referendum on the transcript
of the phone call to we have no
additional evidence from the
whistleblower report that suggests that
Trump was withholding aid in order to
get Biden we don't there are a few
witnesses that are suggested those
people will be questioned but right now
if you're the Democrats you got to feel
like you went out a little bit far on
this limb before all the information was
in opening the impeachment inquiry Trump
will likely be impeached by the house
but if all they've got is what they've
got right now there will be no removal
by the Senate or even a competitive
attempt to remove Trump via the Senate
okay time for thing I like and then a
thing that I hate so things that I like
sometimes cute things happen on TV and
Ellen's show featured this child drummer
really really cute kid whose hero is
Lenny Kravitz and it led to this
extremely adorable moment where this
little talented kid is is playing the
drums and suddenly his hero walks out on
stage which is a cool thing
[Applause]
[Music]
you are amazing
you know I'm a big fan I've been
watching here he didn't know you you
didn't even know that Lenny was here did
you know we kept it very quiet so this
is a big surprise thanks Letty okay that
is cute stuff right there kids are
awesome they really are they're just
great and Ellen's good at what she does
I mean not my cup of tea politically but
she's good at what she does that is it
that is a fun moment okay time for a
quick thing that I hate so it is now
incumbent apparently on every
corporation to virtual say a virtue
signal its way through the world so
Mattel has decided that they are now
going to launch gender inclusive Barbies
because that's what the kids are
demanding of course I have three younger
sisters
I have a daughter this is dumb okay I'm
waiting to see where is the vast where's
the vast outcry and desire for
gender-neutral toys hey in primates in
primates female primates like monkeys
female monkeys will play with dolls and
male monkeys will turn them into weapons
hey there are differences between male
and female and this idiotic
post-feminist
attempt and actually undercuts feminism
the post feminist attempt to suggest
that gender is completely malleable or
that gender neutrality is a thing or the
gender is gendered attributes are
completely disconnected from biology is
completely insane it's completely insane
now is there an actual demand their
company they can do what they want do I
think these things are gonna sell off
the shelves I think they're gonna be
some local parents who feel like better
people for doing this sort of stuff but
it's actually been a problem they did in
Norway and these sorts of toys aren't
selling off the shelves and by the way
aren't impacting the gender gap which
remains very wide in the Nordic
countries specifically because when it
turns out that women live not in poverty
then many of them will opt for careers
that they would rather do as opposed to
careers that pay better I mean really
there's a bigger gender gap in places
like that there are more died I think
the statistic is that there's a bigger
gender gap in Norway than there isnt
Albania and that's because when you live
in a country with poverty women have to
get the best job they can that pays the
most when you live in a country that
does not have poverty then women get to
pick and choose whatever kind of jobs
they won that actually
some weird ways leads to a significant
gender gap and this it but Mattel can do
it wants to do it's a corporation enjoy
but is this really about selling dolls
this really about just free
earned media from a media that is
pushing the absolute lie that gender is
completely disconnected from sex and
that little girls everywhere are
desperate to play with dolls that they
can't tell if they're boys or girls and
come on this is just absolute silly
towns apparently the apparently Mattel
put out a statement they said we see
this line is an opportunity for us to
open up a dialogue around what dolls are
for and who dolls are for we kind of
know they're mostly for girls I mean I
hate to break that to you statistically
dolls are mostly for girls and trucks
are mostly for boys that doesn't mean
that girls can't play with trucks and
boys can't play with dolls and my
daughter when she was like two super
into trucks you know she's into right
now she's five dolls because kids get
more gendered as they get older and
their gender attributes that are natural
and good and distinct that start to
manifest more clearly as kids get older
I love this admit tell says as the world
begins to celebrate the positive impacts
of inclusivity we absolutely
fundamentally believe do his time to
launch a doll line free of labels and
free of rules for kids okay fine so make
all the dolls gender inclusive really if
you really want to go for it Mattel if
you really want to pretend that boys and
girls want to play with the same dolls
and the girls are desperate for gender
inclusive and inclusivity you should as
a way of fighting back against gender
stereotypes get rid of female dolls
entirely they should all be generous I
mean they don't have genitals they
should all be gender inclusive all of
them
well done Mattel you virtue signal to
the world and earn some media today what
grand and glorious world we are creating
for our children and massive confusion
and stupidity okay we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content I'm sure there will be update so
stick around for that
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Serling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you